foreign
and welcome back to another video by
simply learn this is anubhub and in this
video we will be creating a clone of
Facebook but before we begin if you
haven't subscribed to our Channel
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and press the Bell icon so you
will never miss any update from Simply
learn so without further Ado let's begin
and see what's in it for you here we are
going to create a Facebook clone with
the help of react.js but before we jump
to the coding part let's see how the
Facebook login page looks like we'll
open the Chrome
and inside the Chrome we'll type
Facebook
and then
let's see how the Facebook page look
like
this is the home page for Facebook app
this is the header
this is their left and the right hand
side and this is the center we're going
to create everything
so it's just log out this
and let's see the first part of this
video which is the login page
and in this we'll be creating this same
page
using the react
so without further ado
and let's just move into the coding part
I have opened the visual studio code
let's open the terminal I'm entering
Control Plus backlink
this will open the terminal for us in
the terminal to create the react project
we have to write a command npx react
first create
Facebook
please enter
this will take a couple of seconds
let's just wait for a minute
with this command all the npm modules
are being installed
so with this our folder has been
installed now first we'll go to that
folder there you go
and inside that we'll write npm start
let's see
so this is how a phase react app is
shown and we'll make it as this thing
so without wasting any time let's open
our video Studio code and open that
folder that we have created this
Facebook clone
let's cut it inside this inside the
source folder we'll create a folder
called login page
inside that folder we'll create two
files
dot CSS
and one another file called
login
page dot Js
press enter inside this let's see
when the JS file will import the modules
of react by just typing import
to react editor so as you can see the
react modules are being installed in our
system
let's go to the next line and type
import
dot slash login
page dot CSS
okay
CSS
so with this command all the file is be
this CSS file is being fetched to JSI so
let's create the functions for the login
page
inside this function we will create
a
div
included
let's save this but before that you have
to go to our app.js and delete it
and I will write
hello
save this file remove this logo
and import
and then we also have to delete this
react image
enter
let's see what's so hello from singular
so our react project is working fine
let's move on to the Kodi part for this
and just open the file called
m.js
here we'll create
delete this
I'm just right
page
okay
let's just
save this okay
error is shown here so let's fix this
first
okay okay
and this let's delete this line
and it's like this Dave will write the
class name
and the class name for first one is
login
we'll style it after this
second layer
his last name for this will be this book
reset or not this book
and let's create another difficult here
last name and the
phase two text
let's kill this
inside this we'll write this book just
save this file
now
we'll go to this
and
in this I will write
export
okay the return function we have not put
here so we have to write return
inside this everything will come
okay
we need to expose this file
explode default
login
save this
and inside this page I've got JS we'll
see what we have to do
okay everything looks fine in this file
but let's just import the login file
import yes okay the login page has been
successfully imported let's see it is
also control bracket type npm start
let's see what we have done till now
this little Facebook is coming on the
top
now let's go back to the video Studio
code and
come to the app.css control alt delete
save this file now let's see okay cool
we'll sell this after we'll create this
login page
now let's focus on the login page
now
we have to write
the div
which will be the title it's
set as title
now close this file also and in this
title
the
this thing will come
so we'll simply just copy it from there
and inside the folder we'll just paste
it
but as you can see here
it's in different lines so for that
we'll use the break function
how we can use it we'll just have right
here
and then
save this and let's see now
okay cool let's come in nice let's go
back to our code
inside our code we'll just write
another div
let's create now this box
or just let's just dial this first then
we'll create this container
let's just try this thing inside the CSS
part
let's just
say this
everything is safe let's just first make
sides on the body
inside the body on the context
box sizing should be
water box
diagram color should be
F0
F2 F5
and then we'll go to the log component
for this page
inside the login component will give it
a width of an opposing
after that we'll give it a height of 14.
next we'll do the display as licks
after that water is radius of
one minute
alignment should be in the center
the wrap should be headed around only
and the last one should be justified
content and
stages between or let's make it as it is
now we go to our code and see what
changes are there
so as you can see it's showing in the
center with everything just the same
let's just move on to more styling let's
now just create
Facebook text
let's make this text
blue okay the component we will be
styling in this is Facebook text
so for that let's go to the CSS filing
guide dot facebook
dot is used to just fetch the data
let's do the padding here oh one USB
Prime
okay
one ram font size should be 4am
color should be I haven't read down the
color of that
you
double save money
and then f
and the font weight should be more than
700 so let's just save this and see what
changes are done
as you can see the Facebook is coming
that's same only
okay nice note let's move on to the next
component
and the next component should be the
title
let's just fix this by just writing
title dot title
and inside the brackets we'll just give
it a soft
Ware
should be black
and the way it should be
500 and see
it's coming
great
so in the same now
yeah first we'll create the container
here and this will move in this side
let's just move to our code and just
make this the same
let's do the styling again
this let's add the container now
let's write save
class name
let's make it as login
container
inside this there will be some details
inside this we'll write the two input
house
foreign
ER we'll write this thing
if we remove this
it's written email address or phone
number
so this is what is placeholder Android
move to our goal inside
email
address
look
let's break it into
that
we will create another input
let's copy the same thing
here I will write password
and the placeholder right
let's see rupees capital or not
it's capital
okay
now we will create a button
for that login
password
so let's
find this
let's just save and see what's happening
there
small thing has been created till now
we'll style it and make it as this
let's just make this holding
and then we'll style it it's gonna be
cool let's move on to the
button after that I will create
a
not inside this
another disc inside that there will give
it as the
let's just create this forgotten
password
okay
and just choose this and inside that we
give it a tag
right yeah
inside that just save it guys
button
passwords
so
let's give it more space again
okay
now we'll create this button
just create new account button
so that what we will have been I'll be
for that we will be doing is what let's
make another div
or button first button
make it as last name
let's close it and inside that we have
to write
new
account
after this button we will give it some
space
and it's like after that we'll just
write this thing
create a page you have to make this as
on the dark okay cool
back to the coating
let's make it as in there
class name should be
let's make it as a bit
close this
inside this will create an attack
inside that we will write
create
oh here I'll just create to it
after let's close this inside this
see
it after that we'll write that
celebrity business
and now
we have created ours in js5 let's save
it and see how it is on the screen okay
cool
we have to know is style this part the
container one okay
let's move on to the login page or css
and then in the CSS file We'll add some
features
okay
let's start with the container only
login
of Dot
three solid
change it after that we feel
after some time let's just make it a
broad background
the bathroom color should be white
the light should be done and the width
should be at more than 30 you know 2016.
so that let's give it some padding also
of one gram
after the padding we'll give the Border
radius
one future
after this we'll just save it and see
how it's showing okay nice
go back to our code inside that we'll
just type this input email and password
and login container now
login okay got it
input
right
inside the email will write give it a
bit of Android version
waiting off
books in each
let's give it a mark
ers
boxes
okay let's just copy this
paste it right here and inside that
email you will write
sure
and just save it it's showing the error
let's see what's it is
the type
okay
it was deleted so let's save it again
and let's see how it is looking now
let's look in it's
same so let's make it good
and just typing
though
okay
let's just go back to
placeholder first and make it work
this folder inside that case folder font
size
let's say the buttons now
inside this select display
s
to that the direction of the flag should
be given which is
foreign
block sizing
more than watch
ing
should not be although it should be
the first
time
[Music]
just justify content
with a margin of
four pixels two two pixels
okay and the color should be
wait
I'll tell you this
should be nice
okay
that's the Forgotten button let's give
it also some styling by just typing it
the color should be blue only for that
line it in the center
is bye
content should be centered
now the display
should interflex and the context
let's just say this
and see
how it's showing how the login is
showing great
let's just do some one thing
in the container for that is not big
enough so we'll write
this
is trying to find anything if there is
anything missing or not
let's just not move it here so let's
just finish it and then see for other
things that needs to be done
right buttons
the display should be legs
just if I contend Center
align it in Center
should be that it's three one which is
this one
background color off
green and the code for that is 4 2
B 7 2. okay
so we'll give it a border of none
heading should be here also 15 32
let's do the next decoration should be
nice
size should be
first sir
pointer
and the rate should be 60 percent
ages
What's missing
can you just see what you see
okay
let's see
margin left 22 pixels save it
okay good let's give it 20 only
now let's check it it's coming in the
center only great
let's Now do
get each one
says
the color should be
black
and display should be
nice
and then block
and then justify content should be ready
again
and let's take particular is
now let's move on to the page
to the left
let's now do the login details
upstairs
important
let's give it a text
Liberation should be nice
but let's just wait a minute
and
the black
solids
George buckets
decoration should seem nice
here and let's do it let's put the
colors
it should be right for this one
let's just save it and see
okay
it should be coming in the down and
it's just
do it in the bolt
and save it let's see now okay nice
we have to make it outside
for that we have to go here and just cut
this part
and then we have to write it okay just
save it
let's see now
that's coming out
we don't want it out so we'll make it
inside this only
right
this work is let's just save this file
okay but first we'll just hit this
button
now let's save this
I have to do this and this let's see
what's happening here
and inside this
let's see
what's going on okay
this should not be here
because if the placeholder can't be
fixed with a point
so we'll just leave it as input only now
you can see that it's coming the same
make this line here after the Forgotten
okay
let's just go back to the JS file and
read it thoroughly and see if we have
made a mistake
let's see now that we are done with the
home page now let's move on to the next
page let's see
so let's open the Facebook for now
uh let's go to the login page
we just log in
it's asking for the six digit code
let's wait a few seconds and the code is
let's go to our Facebook page
now let's create this
okay let's go back to our code
and let's first I just Ctrl C you can
get the cursor in the console here
select side command
NP let's install
save
yeah
Five Points
8.3.0
uh this package is still installed on my
computer you can install it by this
command okay
okay now I'll just go through this
game start and say it's working
fine okay now we have to make this
broken button
back to our code
let's create a folder
and the source together
area inside this let's create a file
here the area dot CSS and a header
area dot yes okay
now let's import first see that
thank you
going back to him now let's import
the header
area dot CSS file
um
inside this function
it's so stupid is it working fine well
okay
say it this way
let's explore this fight
here
save it
now going back to our index.js file
there we have to not do much anything
everything is installed okay fine
okay
let's go back to our Dodger Style
here we have to declare
a header area
here
we will do what
create a switch
to make
foreign
component
foreign
let's close it now we have to Decay one
more thing
and hold
crowd
and switch
from the art router or react router down
save this file
let's showing some error but let's fix
this
let's go back to our
gold
now let's go back to the login.js page
here
we have to import the link
link
if I just click the link it's hit
imported
now let's create this as a button
it's got this thing and make it as link
yes link to
what the login page
what's this inside this we want to write
a log
save this file
now everything is fine
okay
and say this is fine let's go back to
our code
hit on it again
it's not working I guess let's see
we don't have to declare this thing
again so let's cut this
again save this and Ctrl
and the game start
let's see
what's happening route login is now
defined let's go back to our DOT JS file
here we have to see what's going on
okay without switch
here we have to write the login page
let's save it again and then it's
invited successfully
login code
and when we'll click to login
it's working right
okay let's go back to our code
and see everything is working fine
we have to declare here
now let's redirect this to home page
let's go
inside this we will give
better
area save this you know see
welcome to same feeling now we will go
back to our this page
headed out CSS
now
that we are in either.css
we'll do some changes here and just
let's cut this I can take this let me
start with the logo of Facebook let's
create one class
let's make it as a home page
let's create another diff
last name
is
this as well
inside this we will
create another negative
first here
let's create a logo here
nice name
let's do this as well inside this on the
source
add an image by step in the source the
source of my images
inside the public folder I have folder
called images inside this I have a
picture of logo
images
inside the images
let's save this and see if it changes
that we have done let's
save this and you can see the image here
let's make it as here
okay fine
let's go back to bar
code and see what we have to do
I just oh
[Music]
let's start listening
stylish by doing it full
height
and pixels
close this
and you can see it's coming but it's
very short so we'll give it
seven days more let's give it 50.
50 comes perfect
we'll adjust this in a while
let's do some more changes
and
be able to
skating
okay let's save this and see
the logo padding
it's not again the comma here
save this again it's coming perfect
code
let's
create another class
name
search
let's see like this
search
but they're importing but before that
let's
first
install the react icons
Ctrl C and write a command CPM install
coming back
slash icons
let's see
what
seconds
till then let's invert this okay
let's install it let's write an import
search
slash here
foreign
this let's see
okay let's see what's wrong we are doing
okay
yes
foreign
now let's go back to our code
and see what we can do
we'll style it out the way first create
this
home button
laptop code
let's create this
one more tip
and header
and it will come in the middle
okay let's close this inside this let's
create one another div class
ICS
gone
okay
so you should be
cool
of this this blue
okay
we have this color
save this
okay we have to export this also
let's explore this
we can just inside this
okay if I
said
let's see if I'll just save this as you
can see there's one little
let's increase the size of this home
button
point
five
you can increase the size of this home
button after that but just reduce it by
2.3 would be fine
okay fine
now we need
Americans three four five icons
so let's just copy this thing
five times
4.5
let's
give all the attributes
first one is
and but the second one is f a
C
and the size should be same and
everything should be saved
let's give this one empty
foreign
first
you know
come down they're not just for you
foreign
this one
actually let's again declare this as
well
because this will also come under
another module
what was this one also
if a freaky flag from what you record
yes
I'm going to change this in this
to this
let's change it
now let's take this also
thank you
okay
it's coming all fine
now let's see what clock changes we have
to do now
we should make one home button
let's give it a color of blue 1807 F2
save this in the home color should be
blue you will see the navigation after a
while
now let me know how to create this let's
see how many changes we have to do
now let's create the third header
yeah
let's do it this way
yes
you have to do some
animations and colors after that
image source
I have an image going on
let's
build an image called OneNote gpg
so
first we have declare the folder where
it is
but I just type things
DP
Styles have to get the parts in pixels
that they should take enough
pixels
this should come under the commodities
let's just
listen see the changes
showing you that new images
because
you know what's going to say
it comes that I'd like
to just okay this is
yeah this would be fine
now let's create this playlist messenger
then the notification logo
let's go back to our code
we can find everything looks good
now we have to give up plus class in
glass
said because we're right
Circle
inside your campaign
2.3
pixels
let's just save this
you're not detected yes okay
let's just copy this
thing two and three
Little Joe
foreign
thank you
[Music]
for code
notifications
so we can do changes as well
so let's just cut this
[Laughter]
okay let's not save it see
that's something
now let's just style this let's cut this
this
and this also
open the CSS file
see
the Box
there's a margin
or there's no need of giving margin as
well first let's not give it margin
let's go back to our body part
should be
zero percent margin
is
let's just give it more difficult
foreign
foreign
okay
zero
I don't Focus
margin right
see
let's hung up let's see let's
first let's finish this thing then we'll
do the changes
.css I will edit all the properties of
CSS you can look at this
all the properties are here
[Music]
now
let's see that
this is how it will look
now we'll create the main area for this
page this one right left and the middle
one let's get back to our code
now
here we'll create another folder
called
main area
inside this we'll create two more files
.js
and
the area dot CSS okay
now let's open your main area.js file
inside this
will import that
after the results
okay
Studio of cleaning function
s
save this file let's go back to our
order.js inside this
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's just a c What's Happening Here
cut this thing and let's work on this
mini you know
okay let's cut this
is
[Applause]
on the right side
[Music]
right
after that
the glass middle
Northern India okay
[Applause]
inside
so this
you can see it's coming
okay let's go back to our CSS file
[Music]
let's make this let's flip
now let's do this and you can see it's
coming
as we wanted to be
the same right side middle and the left
side
going back to our chord
and let's see the changes we're going to
be doing in this
let's just do it on the right side
heading height
blue
I need to fix that should be
see it's using the right area
let's begin
let's say it also
see
[Music]
you know I'm coming back
main area code let's discard this thing
should be fine
let's
install the image let me search you can
add an image
I'll have to look for an image
let's see this one this one or this
[Music]
let's add this one
[Music]
ready
let's see this
we need to be heading north
it was just it is just gonna be safe see
it
because we need to clear testing
so we need to change the picture
let me add
a picture of mine here I have any one
picture of mine
let's just say this and see
[Applause]
it's coming from the left side only
let's go back to the code
you can make the size this
so let's get get some styling
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
50 pixels
[Music]
guys
and let's end this
actually looks right here
okay
[Music]
should be fine
it's okay
you're going to deal with the standing
part
let's move forward
[Music]
so let's add two three from here let's
okay
there's so many so we'll add few here
and then this
CMO button let's go back to our code
first thing we'll add your events
positive
control
let's give it the font wasn't
okay I think this is green blue
this one
because we should be
not mod let's
make it as
soon
the color should be
in this size V
let's keep it
do them
just like this
I did because this is not here
this thing
and added
in the top but let's just make others
one also so we'll just copy this
paste and paste
let's just make one for code 19
information center
you have to code
open green and one full
y
that you should be
cool
function between
negative
save it
okay I'm going to keep it upstairs but
it's just continue with what we are
doing
you have created one Facebook Messenger
so let's
create one Facebook Messenger only
okay
so after this so let's
create one Facebook
foreign
he said this last week
let's see
David
inside this Facebook Messenger
all right
it's
save it
come to a
it's a little while so it's just both
the files
from
device
of course in the cloud
come up
come on the last one is
let's just import it from
I have to create one more like this
three folders less let's create one more
thank you
so friends
let's give this user friends color blue
and the phone says should be the same
inside this will right
something
different it's looking good three four
okay
now
forget the name of from
[Music]
stories
now let's save this same it's not
defined
this book
this is the n-g-e-r
which is a mistake let's say it again
I'm not wrong you're thinking about
hey
let's see what's happening here
inside this the main issue is it should
be a bit distinct let's save it now
let's see what to see
yeah
I can't stop the fee
let's see the issues coming in here
it's just
leave and now here you can see another
Facebook and then the discussion between
the left in the right corner in the
middle is still empty and the left it's
still empty lips but in this items one
by one
let's just wait guys
foreign
let's now do some exciting start with
the profile
basically should be Flex in this
enter
once I should
be whatever it would be fine
on repeat 15.
he said to profile
and it would be an image
do this
place should be Flex
not in there
Flex
containment should be centered
but won't say this what one remember
thank you
I read it like 15.
that's coming so small let's introduce
the size
let's give it space
here I have put all the properties of
CSS in this as you can see here in the
left
and the right side I have put all the
properties
the image
through the profile profile images now
you can either start with the metal one
or by the left side but we'll start with
the left side so let's begin
let's first add some shortcuts here
move to the C more
let's go back to our code
you can fade a little down
okay in the main area.js
foreign
class profile
the same thing
let's get the picture here
first.gpt
let's just save it and see it's coming
like this you can just change this that
do not much you know while we will do
that let's copy this again instead
three next one is four
that was good let's do this and see all
the changes it will that put forward
it's okay
let's handle this in the CSS and edited
you to see
now let's just create one last
class for this drop down menu
we'll go back to our code
that this
is
the classroom should be
rows
exclusive
hey
down
down hello
should be
after that
I won't say it should be
okay
100 days
objects can save this see what is coming
very little
so we'll take it from bro
okay
I won't say this one
a let's just save it
let's make it as 1.5
but if you want to learn more about
react you can follow us on YouTube and
there you will find a reactful course
from there you will learn so many things
you can definitely check out that course
coming back to our code let's move on to
JS file
inside that we will find
now let's move on to the left side of
this
first we'll just remove this
from the left
hello
let's save it again
you can find nothing here come back to
our code
we will just type
and let's just do this
[Laughter]
inside this let's create another class
according if
one starts
contact
now
look we'll do it we'll create another
class
you should be
perfect
so this let's create one
video all
inside should be
okay
thank you
let me read your call
video call
or you had icon
slash
it's just now save it you see we have
contact and the video icon
cool right
let's just now open a code now let's
paste some files here
let's just go upstairs and read
okay what's the name
search
copy this
let's take this I have to make another
one
in the same
as much as it does
let's not see this
the terminal they're showing let's see
what's there
save it
it's working fine
you have to add logos here
let's just name it all As
one
two
three
four
five one should be
okay
let's see if this can see the changes
that are done
the only one feature is fetched so let's
see what happened to other ones
coming back to our code
open Dot JP easy this is the path
the file format is gpg it's complicated
here you can see all the locals the
first picture there's no one here logo
so let's
create one
okay one into a b
let's save it
and it's done
foreign
now we'll work on the middle part and
I'll do some few changes here as well
so let's move on to the middle part
now that we are done with the right and
the left part let's work on the middle
part and make this as the full page
Facebook flow
now we'll go back to our code let's see
I've been through changes here
let me show you
like here
now
I have done some let's save this
in changes and CSS file also
you can see here
in some difficult
accordingly
now let's start with the video
okay
let's have this
okay let's go just million receive it
here
and it's removed let's go back to our
code and let's start
classes
thirsty steady
so this will add images
source and to add kubernetes here that I
have
numbered just a second
this one
this one
this one
and this one
let's just read this bit
ahead
we'll have this
first image
let's reading this
okay
let's just copy the image name
and we write this first image
foreign
[Music]
foreign
okay
now everything is fine
let's see
okay
did you see them again and you're just
gonna show you
let's just see why it's natural here
and it is not showing because we have
given very long in the image that name
is so you should be more careful about
the image you are giving the name so
let's just okay
with the eyes of the street
now let's see
okay
next
get played
this you have to make the stories here
so
we'll be right
the name of the image
let's give
it
okay
we'll write the name is
that country stuff
okay but it's closed
so let's after this first one
let's just
cut this part
let's let's just paste this tree
four five
okay
yeah whole images
foreign
let's add the source for these images
save it and see
this is coming right
and also let's change the name to 9267.
PNG
and the last one would be
three two seven nine dot PNG
let's save it now and let's see
foreign
[Laughter]
save it
let's see what's the editor here
okay
let's see
giving some species
he's gonna check whatever it is
okay there it is same here
foreign
now let's move ahead
let's add some thesis properties
so this inside this let's try it dot
inside this
let's make the display okay
of now
[Music]
Captain Center
let's see
okay
this is
let's imagine
of 18 pixels
let's move on
like
to the point they should be
save it you can see
okay
let's see my photo
foreign
and say this
this uh
let's meet this as this
this little love to we need to reduce
the size of this but let's just use this
change it inside this
foreign
disorderly just should be
driven
so that you can see you changes
okay
it's on the street you need it
accordingly so we use another property
of the fix
um why it's not 30 here let's just see
to add in the property here to meet it
like this okay
six
as you know
okay tell me right
see the image of these
okay
let's make this okay
let's just
okay
let's add one more picture
yes
and let's copy this tune again
okay
tell me right
you need to give it more right
so let's go back to our scissors
okay this would be funny
now let's clear this part
live video photo activity and films
and this is
so let's begin
let's go to our videos to your call
so we'll say this
like this
here
let's create
this
glasses
message
last text
after this
one class of
to give the first
it's a better understanding
let's give it a lineage
source
images
folder let's add this picture
okay ing
all right
this let's order this image
would be fine
let's create an important
money
please hold up
music
what's on your mind and love
it's on your mind
of
this whole Space around and then
this one is done
let's create these
icons
let's get some music icon here first
class
God
it's inside this class let's create
another
mean
let's go
looks like this
thank you
so inside this
on images
these are the react icons
which was already going to be created by
Facebook
say this yes
font size of
boobs
inside this let's give it a hardware off
all right
so let's copy this
is
right then
from all right is it true
and go to the last one is
f a
let's give the name
first let's give diff
the first one is live video
second one is
sure
and the last one is
feelings slash
the color of the first one is green
just look image
let's just
Grim was the as this was he
understand the values here
first one if a
let's add here
let's create another one
let's finish this module
hey
image
subscribe
foreign
[Music]
the first one is green
and this one is orange
let's
see wait and see it's coming right
now let's go back to our
this CSS folder
let's now say this
let's come into this I guess
yes
okay
it's not in between this
patiently great
it should be
rim
which should be
assistant
I don't know how it is done that is done
margin to move the left
B
ite
that's just supposed to complete this
and then we'll do that and look let's
now jump to the postcard
prepare we need to get marginal
dog
this place okay
which should be 100
the height should be
five would be fine
let's just let's define this Center
in your background color should be
let's see if background color should be
right
turn your margin left
just the person
okay
let's do more
those books
too much
inside this is
border radius would be
the weight should be
so
minimum
see
goodness increase this
foreign
[Music]
let's do some changes inside this input
that's just
this let's give it over it so
particular person
every month
I could be
especially
[Music]
make it more
attractive
cream
order radius
foreign
okay
foreign
[Music]
box
now
let's go to the
call Button
inside
clicks
item Center
margin of five percent
and then
this is all for this call I guess second
one was equal to investigation we
learned
it flicks it
save it
if I continue
Center or just
started
let's make it as
this week he does
get started now let's see
I'm gonna have to be some pretty good
let's see it's fine
let's move on to this
that's cool
God
let's give
Martin
a little five percent
so in this call
let's simply put back every color
s
but I couldn't
see your energy
foreign
foreign
okay
let's come into one box let's see
how we can make it inside the one box
this is now
now let's rearrange this
from here
it's coming like this we have to be
arranged from this from here to here
let's do this first
now that we are done with this box let's
see
we have created this thing let's do it
inside this let's just cut the margin
Al margin of zero
okay
and then here
let's see
let's cut the margin from here
let's give it 0 and let's save it it's
going fine let's increase the size of
this
let me see
message side should be
25
okay
let's see devices
okay
everything looks good
let's see
it's giving it
base so it's
going fine
we don't need anything else
okay fine this will all look good now we
create this post
for that we'll go and add here in the Gs
file
but div Plus
after this
name
is
rooms okay in this Tech you go to the
Post part
foreign
foreign
image let's drag it inside the image
folder
at centurion.jpg
let's go
inside this I'll write the name of the
image
dot jpg
let's now give it some styling
equals to
the image
it's literally right 50.
let me move to commas 50 pixels
after that let's give it a weird thought
very tough 50 pixels
let's create another device
last name would be
okay
inside this okay
completed
foreign
and after this class
let's create another
picture
last name
I put the
edit
because some people hate it also
so let's write edit
say this let's create an icon off
font size should be
let's get the phone says
1.5
then let's close this to save it
some fitting this including image so
let's see what stage over there
let's find the image where is it so
again and I
a r m
G
what's the issue
I don't understand
let's put it deep into it and see what
station
even given the Border yet so let's give
it a quarter
or flips
the board that we should give
of radius
radius
pixels
now let's see
it's not coming here so it's the problem
with the image okay
you name the folder is images and here I
have written images so let's just save
it again and you can see
there is this the little logo
let's edit it more
and add one big image Here Also let's
add this after this let's create another
class
inside this let's give it a name of
details instruction
s
inside this oven right
comment
subscribe
YouTube channel
let's now endlessly just explained
that's done after this let's give it a
break
after this now we'll add in the image
let's get it close
name of Facebook image
inside this Facebook image without an
image
the images accordingly images inside
that images let's add
this one only simply don't want only
foreign
Spirit would be 100 pixels to be marks
which it
okay
okay now there will write 100 percent
here and let's close it and say this
and now it's great
let me say this let's get another
forward like comment and share part
last name
literally see her
coming in here
you need to move ahead you can see
inside this
mint inside this
active glass of Lake
and
all right
it comes
up the color of that would be great
okay let's close it like
capital
let's go down and the second would be
a minute
great
here's a little great
comment agency
the color would be clearly
comment and here we'll eat
good [ __ ]
that's right
let's save oops let's recommended for
you
so very very first one
okay
second one
it's okay
[Music]
let's now see if I can see
what's happening on our page
as you can see the whole tree has been
created
let's now edit here
and add some cool features
let's just wait for a few seconds
after that we'll add here the properties
of CSS
let's go to
property tag
inside this let's make the container
let's start with the posted one
okay
display should be grid
at that
height
so the width of this should be 80
percent the rest would be fine the line
items clicks Dot
everyone down because it would be your
weight
after that
one percent only just a week a little
different
after that let's go to our
poster
inside this poster let's add this clay
should be a legs
justify content should be space between
after that let's go do something
[Music]
let's kill it
display of clicks
after that let's begin just the freaking
tension b space between
the margin of 72 pixels and the fonts it
should be
or one I guess
from now on let's create one we can
change it also let's save it and see
if it's coming
it's great let's create a few more
things
okay
which let's
we have to add one space here also so
let's add here one space
let's see what station
no
I see
we can just make it
okay let's see I got to do here also the
editions so we can create it after a
while
let's move on to more with CSS only
let's add this
update
what's the name of this
right update it's
I did this
update
I would say it should be
going through which should be
at 400
something
that's 15 pixels save it
okay
[Music]
let's see
it's raining
it's on it and see if you can do it
we need a little more
yeah that's cool we will just do this
after a while
let's just make this right first
simply done okay fine everything looks
good
let's do some addition here on top of
that will fix it
inside this pixel
after that let's give it and this one is
complete I did
and it it's done
it's right now
the part is captioned it's
so many distinct on the caption
caption which one says should be
3.3
true
it should be 500
word
grab a little Creekwood
the padding lifter is important so it
give focus in the same and see
it's coming
okay fine
let's see
thank you
I will deal with this like midential
part
okay
let's do this
let's add a disk read and then the like
button
okay
so this is okay
Netflix
justify content
is around
I could be favorite
um
[Music]
let's create one like
let's try this let's give it a display
of flexibility
should be
an item Center
for the weight
would be 400
after that
let's change the size of that font
and make it a little big
let's see if we can see
it's coming like this
I think now we need to edit this thing a
little
so let's edit this open video Studio
code
fine for this let's add it here this
part
so let's do it here
inside this let's give it a huge
excuse me
okay
whatever radius of 1.5 minutes
to the margin of zero
you know let's activate it should be
here if it would be the same
enough
yes
Flex slots
this should be interested it's a bad
here here I have seen the width of this
post do 80 percent this will
automatically reduce the length of that
and after that here also I have include
in the call that it should be 80 then
this left part would be
free
so
we are done with our clone you can add
some images here to make it more
attractive so with this we're having the
end of this video let's see
let's I'll demonstrate you okay you will
write your email ID your password and
you'll just click on login and then your
page will be open so with this we have
read the end of this video we have read
the end of this video make sure to like
share and comment thank you for watching
stay tuned for simply
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here